today I'm going to show you how to make
a quick smoothie that will be full of
nutrition and the kids will love it
it literally takes under a minute all
you need is some kind of finger and
leftover fruits that you can put into
your smoothie so I've got one of my
bananas here that I probably wouldn't
use because it's got to be end of its
life I'm gonna peel that and put that in
there then I'm going to add some orange
juice lots of Italy see in there and
[Music]
right now that we could be enough but
and some people want to buy frozen fruit
obviously it keeps its nutritional value
more and so I'm gonna just chop in three
in your eye without having to eat fish
and I can suggest some flaxseed this is
brilliant in all sorts of sources and I
always add a little bit to my smoothies
and again just to get that little bit of
a nutrition
okay and he have your orange juice you
have your banana and as a sign of adding
some frozen fruit as well so you've
probably got about three of your five a
day there and you have a delicious movie
that everyone will love another
important thing to remember is make sure
you recycle all your food waste in your
food carry the recipes like this one and
other tips and hints on how to eat well
and waste less you can get one of these
cookbooks from the council free of
charge with lots and lots of tips